a Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
has become a symbol of everything the
Republican Party stands against everyone
gets a right to basic health care we
need strong oversight of these banks a
legal scholar and a consumer advocate
turned politician wore on his branded
herself as a champion of the working
class and made a career out of standing
up to big business while rumors of a
20/20 presidency bid remained just that
I'm not running for president her Senate
seat is up for re-election in 2018 and
Republicans are already pumping millions
into super PACs to the theater this is
the story of how a law professor and
politician came to be seen as the
biggest threat to Republican values and
the greatest hope for progressive
America Elizabeth Warren was born
Elizabeth and Herron the youngest of
three siblings On June 22nd 1949 in
Oklahoma City two middle-class parents
after waiting tables to help her family
pay the bills Warren became a star on
the high school debate team she landed a
scholarship to George Washington
University at the age of 16 but two
years later dropped out to marry her
high school sweetheart Jim Warren by
1980 Warren was a mother of two divorced
and remarried had earned a bachelor's
degree from the University of Houston a
juris degree from Rutgers and practicing
law in New Jersey Warren then went on to
become an influential law professor
teaching lecturing and publishing highly
cited work on bankruptcy and commercial
law at seven universities around the
country eventually settling at Harvard
Law School but Warren wasn't always a
liberal lion Elizabeth Warren used to be
a Republican actually that's Steven
Dennis I'm a Senate reporter for
Bloomberg
around the time that Elizabeth Warren
switched parties she became a fierce
opponent of a Republican Drive but make
it much harder to file for bankruptcy
she fought that for a decade it ended up
passing anyways while her efforts
ultimately failed her
calls were heard in 2008
we're in the midst of a serious
financial crisis our entire economy is
in danger and without immediate action
by Congress America could slip into a
financial panic and a distressing
scenario would unfold professor Warren
was tapped to help with oversight in the
government bailout she would excoriate
bankers and their bonuses and their
practices why should the US taxpayer
alone carry City she proposed all series
of tough regulations which became the
basis for much of the dodd-frank
financial law that we have today that
sort of catapulted her to national
stardom particularly among the
progressive left encouraged by her
newfound notoriety Warren declared her
bid for the US Senate on September 14th
2011 during the race for opponent Scott
Brown tried to derail Warren by accusing
her of falsely claiming Native American
heritage a controversy that earned her
the nickname Pocahontas
nevertheless she was victorious and won
the Senate seat by a comfortable margin
she used her new tenure to challenge
everyone from banking regulators and
Treasury officials to members of Wall
Street in Congress we need tough new
laws to hold corporate executives
personally accountable no one should be
above the law she called for Wells Fargo
CEO John stump to resign for fraud
introduced the bank on student loans
Fairness Act and reintroduced the 21st
century glass-steagall Act
in 2016 after staying silent during the
Democratic primary battle Warren finally
endorsed Hillary Clinton and had some
harsh words for candidate Trump Donald
nasty thin-skinned fraud who has never
risked anything for anyone and that it's
just one of the many reasons he will
never be President of the United States
but she was wrong forgotten men and
women of our country will be forgotten
no longer worn wasted no time resisting
Trump's agenda I have not how about a
billion dollar loan program I have not
in the Donald Trump era Elizabeth Warren
has been playing defense and trying to
prevent Donald Trump and his cabinet
appointees from rolling back protections
that she helped enact Warren actually
found herself rebuked by Mitch McConnell
for reading a letter by Coretta Scott
King about Jeff Sessions record on
racism during his confirmation she was
warned she was given an explanation
nevertheless she persisted that moment
became something that's on t-shirts
bumper stickers slogan and that really
galvanized a lot of support for her it's
been very hard for Republicans to get
much of anything done this year and
that's at least in part to this
resistance movement that Elizabeth
Warren has helped champion like millions
of dollars are being funneled to defeat
Warren in the midterm elections in 2018
but it's the rumors of a 2020
presidential bid that is further
prompted powerful donors to fund her
opposition often using the same playbook
constant and ruthless ad campaigns that
many believe helps trump win in 2016
it's anyone's guess if she will endure
what Hillary could not you know the
question for Elizabeth Warren is whether
she can go from being a liberal
firebrand to somebody who can regularly
get 60 votes for initiatives in the
and 218 in the house and drive an agenda
and whether she can bring together
coalition's for political victories that
to the challenge and we'll see what
happens
you
you